je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Philippe Vigier
pour le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre
madame messieurs les ministres monsieur
le ministre de la Santé mes chers
collègues
si ce n'était un sujet aussi grave que
celui de la sécurité sociale de ces
branches
n'oublions pas un héritage partagé un
héritage commun fruit de la résistance
un modèle unique unique en Europe unique
dans le monde et bien on ne pourrait en
parler avec légèreté mais là on doit en
parler avec gravité
je reviendrai une seconde chère Caroline
Fiat si j'ai beaucoup apprécié je vous
le dis je l'ai dit à des collègues votre
témoignage à un moment hier de la
soignante face à cette pandémie et je me
suis retrouvé dans vos mots je me suis
moi retrouvé dans vos mots tout à
l'heure parce que je sais que vous êtes
capable lorsque l'essentiel est en jeu
comme vous l'avez très mis à fait sur la
mission sur les EHPAD travailler avec
des membres de la majorité pour faire en
sorte qu'on trouve des propositions
constructives et je voudrais juste vous
dire également mais avec beaucoup de
calme et sans esprit polémique j'ai pas
compris pourquoi votre groupe politique
qui est dans l'ordonnancement des niches
puisque c'est vous qui avez la main pour
organiser cette journée vous n'ayez pas
démarré par naturellement la
réintégration des personnels soignants
n'aurai eu toute la journée pour pouvoir
en discuter cela m'a un peu surpris il
est vrai que vous souhaitiez démarrer
par le pouvoir d'achat et on s'est
retrouvé avec une proposition de loi sur
l'IVG pour le constitutionnaliser et là
d'ailleurs ça a été dont vous
m'accorderez que c'était un moment
partagé pour cette hémicycle puisque sur
tous les bancs nous sommes arrivés à un
consensus le Pilates ce qui démontre que
il faut laisser je pense les manœuvres
un moment ou un autre mais je souhaite
cher Caroline Fiat et je vous le dis
dans les yeux qu'à un moment ou un autre
on puisse avoir un débat de fond sur les
sujets de vaccination et là je suis
persuadé d'une chose c'est que
l'objectivité dans vos propos
rencontrera la mienne et celle très
largement de l'ensemble des membres de
cette émission
alors
évidemment un 49,3 un 49,3 c'est
toujours ressenti pour un parlementaire
comme une forme de brutalité mais permet
de rappeler à notre collègue d'air qui
est qui appartient à républicain il
connaît parfaitement la façon dont a été
élaborée la Cinquième République et la
Constitution par Michel Debray je
voudrais pas avoir la violence de
rappeler d'ailleurs les mots de Michel
Debré lorsque Simone Veil était à la
place les frères Riester à côté des
Jacques Chirac 1er ministre des mots
extrêmement violents qui avaient été
prononcés contre elle en 1975
lorsqu'elle portait cette voie
courageuse pour faire en sorte que les
femmes puissent avoir le droit à
disposer de leur corps moi j'ai pas
oublié tout ça et je voulais vous dire
et je voulais vous dire chers collègues
Neder que d'ailleurs c'était extrêmement
à charge votre propos pendant quelques
minutes puis après vous êtes rendu
compte que on ne pouvait pas suivre
naturellement les insoumis sur cette
notion de censure alors évidemment je
m'adresse à au ministre de la Santé en
lui disant cher ministre de la santé que
et vous l'avez dit vous-même c'est un
budget de transition mais pensons chers
collègues pensons chers collègues
l'héritage qui est le nôtre et quand je
lis d'ailleurs quand je lis d'ailleurs
Caroline Fiat dans le texte de votre
monsieur de censure je prends un seul
exemple tellement il a destructuré
complètement l'hôpital français c'est la
fameuse taxe la tarification à
l'activité et laborée entre les années
2012 et 2017 je sais l'arme de
destruction massive que cela a pu
représenter dans l'ensemble de
l'organisation hospitalière française et
que je sache entre 2012 et 2017 et bien
c'était un gouvernement de gauche qui
était en responsabilité alors que la
maquette soit imparfaite bien sûr que la
maquette soit améliorée évidemment
regarde le ministre en charge de nos
aînés et là encore là encore ion je
crois la modestie de rappeler que cette
loi grand âge annonçait depuis tant
d'années où était-elle où est-elle mais
reconnaissons quand même cher Caroline
que le seul gouvernement qui a eu le
courage en 2016 en du constitué de faire
en sorte que l'on puisse établir les
prémices et après et bien la cinquième
branche a été créée dans le quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron est nul ne peut
s'opposer à cela alors
je vais vous dire que dans ce budget moi
j'ai des regrets mais je salue aussi les
avancées ce qu'on va faire en matière de
prévention est une avancée considérable
monsieur le ministre je vous invite à
aller plus loin et notamment à s'occuper
également de la prévention chez les
enfants quand on sait que
malheureusement la santé des enfants est
souvent en péril fuck justement des
personnels soignants sur les territoires
les avancées voyez on a eu cette loi
constitutionnelle hier sur la
proposition de votre présidente qui est
là je rappelle que la pile du lendemain
et bien elle figure là dedans le
meilleur recouvrement on le sait pour
les familles pour les allocations
familiales c'est quelque chose qui est
dedans
quelques avancées aussi j'aurais
souhaité que ça aille tellement plus
loin quand on connaît mon caractère sur
ces questions là notamment d'accès aux
soins ou le cumulent leur retraite enfin
nous avançons et donc monsieur le
ministre je vous implore que sur les pas
du on puisse trouver des solutions de
manière à ce que c'est 10000 pas de lui
qui existent et pour lesquels il y en a
au moins 2500 ou 3000 mobilisables on
arrive demain à leur proposer de
travailler pour l'hôpital public ou pour
la sphère privée arrêtons ces silos qui
ne servent à rien si la médecine marche
mal à l'heure actuelle c'est parce
qu'elle est en silo et comme elle est en
silo on se parle pas de la même façon
chers Caroline Fiat que sur une piste
d'athlétisme l'aimant ne se croisent
jamais il faut en sortir alors mes chers
collègues je vais vous dire madame la
Première ministre que vous pourrez
compter sur le groupe démocrate merci de
votre écoute sur les médicaments et
d'ailleurs
tout ce que nous avons entendu sur des
pénuries d'amoxicilline ces derniers
jours même si le ministre nous a rassuré
dimanche dernier ça veut dire que la
réappropriation de l'industrie
pharmaceutique il faut absolument la
conduire monsieur le ministre c'est pour
vous un enjeu considérable et on compte
sur vous pour y arriver la deuxième
chose au-delà de l'action au soin
naturellement c'est le grand âge et sur
ce grand âge j'espère qu'on pourra
dégager il y a 3000 créations de poste
en 2023 certes il faut aller plus loin
on en convient tous on en convient tous
mais combien avait été créé Caroline
Fiat en 2016 vous voulez que je vous
redonne le chiffre vous voulez je vous
redonne le chiffre c'est deux fois moins
alors moi je suis très à l'aise vous
dire simplement que il nous appartient
de réorganiser nos systèmes de santé et
je vais vous dire madame la Première
ministre monsieur le ministre madame
monsieur les ministres quelques lignes
un peu qui sont les nôtres des lignes de
force pour faire en sorte que ces
systèmes de santé soient plus efficients
le problème mes chers collègues
c'est pas uniquement un problème de
moyens 550 milliards comparez-le j'ai
fait ce travail de comparaison avec tous
les pays de l'Union européenne et du
pays qui nous entoure avec une meilleure
efficience chers collègues de der vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure arrêtons
d'avoir et la crise covid a été un
formidable révélateur et on doit ça à
nos personnels soignants tous les
Français qui les ont appelés à 20h on
leur doit de la dignité on leur doit se
travailler de reconstruction de
l'ensemble du système de santé comment
voulez-vous qu'il s'y retrouve entre
santé publique France la DGE la
Direction générale de la santé les
différentes ARS
mais ça devient totalement il y avait
même vous vous en souvenez tous les
doubles comptes le week-end parce que le
week-end lorsqu'on mourrait en EHPAD
c'était pas la même agence qui
transmettait au ministre je dis la
vérité il faut réformer cela en
profondeur deuxièmement monsieur le
ministre et je parle sur le contrôle de
la première ministre madame la Première
ministre je pense qu'il faudrait
pour notre hôpital et système de santé
depuis largement que l'on soit capable
d'avoir une loi de programmation
sanitaire sur plusieurs années avec des
clauses de revoyure avec des évaluations
pour voir les besoins l'adaptation aux
besoins de manière qu'on a rapporte une
réponse puissante et que ça permet
d'entraîner largement l'ensemble du
parlementaire sénateurs et députés sur
des objectifs à atteindre une troisième
chose c'est une réforme de l'État qui
devient omnipotent totipotent trop
centralisé et lorsqu'il y a ces
centralismes au bout d'un moment
l'efficacité n'est plus au rendez-vous
appuyons-nous sur ce qui se passe dans
les territoires vous avez un très bel
exemple agnès-sur-mer le Baudelet
connaît très bien ce sont les fameuses
communautés professionnelles
territoriales de santé 34% du territoire
national est actuellement maillé à
chaque fois ça se passe bien c'est là où
on invente des soins non programmé c'est
là où on a des réponses que l'on peut
apporter j'arrive à directrice d'hôpital
au téléphone en venant ici tout à
l'heure qui me confirmait c'est osmose
toujours plus forte entre la ville et
l'hôpital allons-y monsieur le ministre
et allons-y fortement les collectivités
territoriales vous êtes tous attachés
aux collectivités territoriales de non
plus de compétences à nos départements
je dis au ministre en charge du grand
âge parce que le Bien vieillir c'est une
exigence par rapport à ces générations
et nous devons la porter par rapport aux
régions allons plus loin sur la
formation nous avons voté madame la
Première ministre un texte sur la VAE il
y a quelques jours donnant région cette
capacité d'aller plus loin donnons leur
aussi la capacité de travailler un peu
comme dans les cas des contracts avec la
région des manières Christophe béchuella
de manière à ce qu'en matière de santé
état et régions se mettent naturellement
en lien pour se donner des grands
objectifs marcéno le sait très bien dans
la région qui nous est chère et bien la
pue des articles de France on serait
capable avec la région d'apporter de
meilleures réponses
alors cette gouvernance des hôpitaux il
faut la revoir avec aussi une exigence
parce que personne n'en parle et pour
moi c'est une question de démocratie
sanitaire il y a une loi qui a été votée
vous en souvenez en 2002 mais tout le
monde l'a oublié il dit quoi la loi 2002
elle dit que le patient on doit le
mettre aussi au cœur du fonctionnement
de nos hôpitaux donc cessons d'avoir ces
hôpitaux uniques chers Caroline Fiat je
vous ai parlé avec le plus grand calme
et je continuerai de le faire jusqu'à la
fin de mon intervention chers Caroline
Fiat vous qui aimez bien
j'ai le temps encore vous qui aimez bien
être au cœur de l'organisation des soins
simplement je propose que l'on puisse
inciter les patients qui ont une
expérience au vu de l'hospitalisation
vue de leur parcours de soins dans cette
gestion de manière à ce que à côté des
médecins du corps médical à côté des
administratifs les patients puissent
avoir un rôle absolument central il
s'agit de l'efficience il s'agit
naturellement de ce que nous devons
parce que le mot sécurité sociale ça
n'est pas n'importe quoi il y a le mot
sécurité qui est un mot très puissant et
social et bien c'est naturellement
l'arc-en-ciel de tout ce qu'on doit
apporter en termes de solidarité
j'aurais terminé par des enthousiasme et
de l'espérance parce que je suis
persuadé mes chers collègues que
par-delà nos différences lorsqu'il
s'agit du plus gros budget les 550
milliards Gabriel attaque numéro de
rapace c'est plus que le budget général
du pays lorsqu'on a un tel budget géré
et bien on doit s'y fixer ses objectifs
et ses objectifs ils doivent se faire
sur une nouvelle architecture et cette
nouvelle architecture madame la Première
ministre la porteront avec vous si vous
souhaitez que nous allions sur ce chemin
en attendant vous pouvez compter sur le
soutien indéfectible du groupe démocrate
merci
beaucoup mon cher collègues